you
so i'm gerry i work at me to do I both
like software and devops engineer and
talking today about modern and how you
could actually roll your own modern
based off this like core abstraction in
nerve huh screams it's a little overview
we talked about like where's my RN
metrics then get into like jeans as like
this very very useful for abstraction
that like a little hard to like a little
hard to crop but like with a little
massaging I give it starts the sense to
make sense and then Nigel step and I'll
go into a lot demo work oh I will go
through scratch or ideally i'll go to
those from scratch may a little like
monitor like proxied HP server step 7 so
monitoring metrics like what like what
is this in like how do i do it like we
need when you start building your
application like modern can be like hard
thing like all right what am I supposed
to monitor like what do I need to log
all these such a things like get come up
but you're just trying to go there
application you want to work whether
it's like a a little web application or
or just like a this one I hope poster
website but like say you might be doing
something like not work not quite your
side just crashing like right where you
start to like discern the problem so
like like the thing like simple monitor
is easy in a sense where this is the
first thing mon mon especially when
using
is like memory is like your big spot
apart like CPR usually completely fine
but if you're abusing memory and you're
not like running on a server that has an
extreme amount of memory like you're
just like buffering everything into
memory and not getting rid of it but
this can become a problem just like
crash your circle started logging like
logging is in my mind like modern at one
point out is I just log everything like
this this can be like taxing on Io if
like you know start getting water a bus
but i think the transparency knowing
what they're doing is the fourth it and
just basically arts like any any part of
your program where like it could
potentially crash like the whole way to
do this nose like process uncaught
exception like something absolutely
terrible happen with your application i
extend yourself email or like something
i think that's that's like the best I
guess best place to start because I see
a lot of a lot of people run of this
problem we're like their app like just
crashes too many times and like
something seriously mysterious happens
and now it's like them and they have no
idea why so like even when your side
building a little basic like HTTP
application I think that's that's like
the best place to start so like why is
monitoring so important like logging
being the being the first step like
that's I guess the
yeah doctor lawyer scale this is this is
where like having Norman monitoring
system becomes becomes a better strategy
is like now if you have more than one
server that you're managing like how do
you get all those logs that you're using
for your like your basic honoring in
like one place intelligence got in your
alerts so now like know you have your
head new processes that like all right
if it crashes on your vmail but like
what if what if you didn't want to do
that every time with there are certain
areas that you can you recovered from
what if there are I guess what if
there's like more data you can gather
from like when something goes wrong like
this is where you want you want to start
sending out more data and maybe make
decisions based on that data so like you
want more data in mex inspect
application we're like first one like
start with memory like if your memory
bits over certain percentage like there
might be something wrong with the server
like there you know there might be
something wrong to your application you
want to be notified maybe not like you
know every time like memory spikes but
if it like hovers at a certain threshold
for too long that might be a better
indicator of like what happens as
mentioned you wanna make decisions on
this data you're producing memory being
like the first one for you
decisions on like response time like
there are a lot of like different
different variables that you can start
coming out of your application so in
like this is the this is why it's so
important that you want to avoid the
case of human modern especially by users
I unfortunately had to deal with some of
this we're like you never want to be the
guy that's like hey like your thing that
I depend on like it's not working and I
have to be that guy the other day cuz
like in order to run a full replica like
we rely on like him p.m. to have a
database and replicate from or like one
of their databases to be up like up to
date so that we can create our own
database from like a metadata and I
haven't in that guy of the day I hate
that guy where it's like why is this not
working or why why is it not I guess
working as it should so that's don't you
know what that and so like talk about
honoring the the first thing I I guess
is the second thing I hooked up honor to
say like the old empty of architecture
we we depend on just like replicating a
bunch of caches together and making sure
today they stayed like insistent and
we're making sure the replication was
always up in right that was that was the
big thing and because like cash TV has
like has this bug that there's now a
patch for that because when you're
replicating with your binary data it can
actually just get stuck we're like
Erlang has some crazy pattern matching
like function that wasn't just wasn't
running efficient nothing that would
just feel like
like okay didn't replicate try and we
try and get stuck in this like infantry
tribal and that would like a lot of
things do you like get out of sync and
the only one way I figure out how to fix
that is just completely kill replication
and started everything so I have this
this process that specifically modern
well Matt and handle the auto fix it but
there are there are cases where like it
might not be able to fix it for whatever
reason like if something terribly wrong
happens like there you know you need to
be notified or because i have this
external process to just listen on
changes feeds it made it easier to like
I was not monitoring externally so that
was handling most of the work but if
something wrong happened like I need to
be notified so this is where like custom
events in monitoring become useful for
geologists you know moderate memory and
be able like you know do do some math on
your memory research and make decisions
on that being able to define custom
events can be very powerful it's like
now you have granular control over the
type of monitoring you're doing fine
gratification so like for an example
like how how it detected when the I
guess when our replica was like I have a
specific event where if I'm not if I'm
no longer getting changes from like a
couch and usually with like with how in
camp works there's always like a change
at least every 10 minutes like if if not
more because people are just like
constantly publishing update modules
which is awesome so it's like if I'm not
receiving any changes from like from
that database then that clearly
indicates a problem and also like
another big use case for like
deal with is like in airlie distributed
architectures we're like we run this
clock as a service identity and in order
to do like blogging for like all these
like that since the service that we keep
up and running like that has to be done
over the network and that has to be like
I'm engaged and like stored like
somewhere so the way we forgot to do
that is we now have what's called like a
little Asian pork producer on any one
server so when you deploy your arbitrary
JavaScript to know Jitsu you get wrapped
in this this process called Fort Sill
what force it does it's like hey I got
your application i'm going to keep this
up and running and every time we like
all longer it out i'm going to like send
this as a little json json packet like
over over tcp and now we have these
servers these video servers which all on
the tog together which then take that
JSON back at no I oh I know this is a
log from like this user and now I can
put this in a like particular like I
guess list in reps and also send this
over post up so now i can make decisions
based on that data format i get i can
basically filter out a bunch of streams
split them and just like send these
separate streams all the different
locations and this is all done like very
efficiently so this is that's just like
one example where this was necessary I
need in order to in order for this to
work I needed to have like a middleman
essentially in in the mix that was like
aggregating all the data and then
putting it somewhere I do
I did not have control of the users
process so I couldn't just like make
sure that logging out since log leaf or
made sure that I guess like they were
using some white other logging transport
besides like the console so that was the
like that does the solution there so now
we're talking a little bit about
streaming so place your hands like who
here had like who your head like I was
like very familiar with them and as like
has you screams oh okay some of you all
right so like who here has like built
like a little express at something okay
all rights more hands so you've actually
eve touchscreens you might not have used
the actual streaming methods but like
every core um I guess anything you're
getting data from a note like whether it
be a request or response or I you know
you can actually create a reading from a
file like these are all all these like
these this stream abstraction so I put
it was I didn't mean so no it actually
took streams from like the days of
minutes and I was loved showing this
book because the the doodoo wrote it is
the like the grandfather extremes so
read it we should have some ways of
connecting programs like garden hose
screwing another segment when it becomes
necessary and massage data in another
way this is the way I by Austin so like
what you're describing is like in UNIX
you have these commands like cat and
grip like these are actually all like
little streaming components where you
can cat they file and now you can pipe
that into integrex which then my acts as
a filter so now you can filter by an
arbitrary regular expression or by like
you know some kind of like key sorts and
that's really powerful and like node
node uses that very well so it can
anybody something who
you actually said this quote anyone
dennis ritchie now actually it's scott
Doug McElroy who like you haven't heard
home go look mom this is pretty cool
dude so like this where the square came
from is like it's came from early this
unit allowed to like very easy
separation of concerns with like I guess
they a common thing which was like
standard naming standard app like these
were like two basic appellant like
conscriptors no way but like they are
basically these two mechs mechanisms
that like all right if I just cooked it
and just standard in send it through
this program if it can interpret that
data then you can like type of life type
that exam to another program like that
was that that pipe in connecting
mechanism and it in by utilizing this
interface allows you to like optimized
for like plugging things together we're
like the greatest thing about news that
there are all these modules in NPM and
if like I asked them more like anything
that's doing with data it more than our
our streams now they've become
inherently more plug because like now
this is this common interface that like
works with file system works with like a
request if I can start like sending data
from any one of these like those pieces
of node into like any arbitrary stream
do i do an operation like that becomes
really powerful so here's like there's
like one I guess one example is a known
like subway speaker Larry I talked about
like
the file system by both our quest
response and dislike read stream from
the file system they're like they're all
the same thing they're almost like
different flavors of the streams so what
happens here is that every time a
request sense this used to be served
like it's like okay I need to send this
this piece of HTML data plan and what so
what this bar string equals evidence not
creepy read stream what that's going to
do that it's going to start pulling the
data from the file system bit by bit and
it's not going to wait for all that data
to get aggravating that it's that stream
variable it's like I mean we're
screening so what we can do now is like
I can just redirect that data right back
to the response so I'm just going to
start like pulling this data out and I'm
just like okay I i know this data is
that this data is not flowing so i'm
just going to type this to this response
so that actually like optimizes for like
your memory footprint so like your will
use the least amount of memory in this
situation because you're not offering
all of that into memory we're going to
offer as much as it needs to internal so
you actually don't worry about it at all
so like that's an example of a
particular time a stream or I guess the
request is a particular example stream
like a wrinkle stream and along with
that stream that I create from Boston
those are both read miss rooms so then
you can think about a reboot gradable
stream this is a source a source of data
that you either want to pull from or
like just like send all the data out and
might push it somewhere else and there
are a few different
streams that are built in minus the
others like a regular where the response
in that particular case with the right
mystery now i can i can type that or i
can just write i can write chunks of
data to it and then maybe like then and
that's going to be like okay I've
written I've written all the did I
believe the zune and now i'm outside a
duplex cream which is like kind of a
good thing to think about is actually
both a readable and writable street so
the best example I have is like think
about like a telephone when you're
talking something on the phone like
you're both like talking to them like so
you like your right to information into
the phone and you're also listening so
you can like that's like your brain is
like reading information from them while
on salvia right so it's just like this
two-way communication pathway and then
there's a special form of a duplex train
glycol transform streams which is like
what we're going to what I'm going to
talk about a lot with though with heavy
dopers so a transform stream is just a
much simpler mechanism where you get
data you put it in this transform soon
that's going to take each chunk it's
going to do some kind of operation to
the chain and then keep passing it
through so you do think about like if
you want to take a bunch of data like
Saints it's all I got here all like
string data you can take that data I can
do a transform stream that will now
assuming that that like I guess that
stream of like text data that that was
actually like say
json but it was just like text form you
can actually turn that the JavaScript
objects I just pepping into a movie
screen so look over some iced extreme
properties we're now like when with
introduction was true too we have this
internal buffering I'll take 40 so like
earlier doing like back in like 06 or a
for you actually did have that where as
soon as you perceive a request from the
server if you try to do some like a sync
operation I look up some all you have
you could actually lose data so like
something is doing like a poster of cook
requesting like that day of those data
events to start firing off you actually
have a good advantage that buffering
yourself ended up being like that was a
little complex for people to to handle
it like it's like you don't you don't
expect that so now we actually have this
the central buffering and that's where
this high watermark dungeon where if
you're if you're creating a stream like
yourself or like is writing a screen you
can set this high watermark value to be
like anything you want this this just
dictates how much data should be
buffered like internally so like like
say you set the high-water mark to
infinity and you just like type of a
bunch of data to a stream you can
actually run to that same like memory
problem because if you don't have that
extreme it's buffering all that data if
you don't actually keep sending that
somewhere you can even still like
regular mmmm and have that
exact wrong and one thing that became
popular ended around the stream
abstraction was creating objects
different so internally node just deals
with text and binary screams so it's
just you know you're getting game from
the file system that's all the either
utf-8 i call this binary data you can
vary text but it's just all these ladies
string-based my clone ass now like
people in the user space like in like
Republican miles and p.m. that we're
using these students including
differently it's like instead of on each
data event just having like say I know
five bytes of data like what if you just
you want to make sure that you're
dealing with a whole object so now like
there's this mechanism where it's like
okay I can just deal with like each time
I get a date event like I know that's
going to be a complete JSON object that
I can now do things with that's actually
I think much more powerful like we're
running a user application in music
streams because like it's hard to think
about like how would you transform like
some binary data and actually like I
guess unless you're like writing a
protocol or like I'm doing something of
that nature like what do you need to
parse that binary did it for a lot of
times we're just dealing with like JSON
objects and maybe just like serializing
that from like just string in addition
so that that's actually like a really
powerful property
now those in the in 0 about 12 is
actually have now a more formalized
mechanism for like this flowing course
not flowing which is as I mentioned like
using either using a date of em which
like if you put a data listener on a
string that's you're just going to start
firing off data and like what was
introduced in string 2 is this like non
flowing where now you get request this
data actually is paused by default it's
going to internally buffer that request
data because like you don't want to lose
any of it and you can use it you can use
that stream data where I guess get the
data out of it if you're not using this
this like magical pipe method which I
shouldn't before you listen on this
readable event so what like readable
describes like okay tell me when this
particular Street saves a request I'm
like posting you like a giant JSON
object and like I just want to know like
when like when I'm going to get some
some chunks of that data this readable
event is fired as soon as like some of
those chumps make it to that HTTP server
and now now this introduces like a pull
mechanism where I use this this bar
chunky will stream not read this read
function is like you pulling data out of
the stream where I guess the opposite
side of it you add a data listener that
data is just being pushed at you like
it's going to like just give it to you
as soon as
tality it's now like any Ella care like
any any questions regarding streams
because like this is this is like a core
thing I want I want you all going again
define without partisan the data how do
you define and cuddle with the data in
the buffer there's enough so that you
can parse the JSON mantra for instance
or online about five or whatever so I
don't want to have to climb a clock well
that's like a lot of times like reading
these problems that somebody's are you
solved it for you there are like some
modules one particular like JSON stream
where like what it does is like as soon
as you're getting data you're getting
data you're actually attempting we're
going to attempt to json.parse so this
is this modules like made violent former
engineer eyes like where it parses line
to learn to JSON so it's going to get
get a bunch of data it's going to try
and do a json parser that fails then
it's going to wait for more data and
then just like buffer as much as like
it's gotten at that point and then as
soon as that json.parse oopsies then now
i can take that object and then push it
to the internal buffer of the street
because now like in that case he made an
object stream that then takes binary
data and then is now converting those
into just objects so that that's like a
the transform stream work I actually use
it in England oh where I just take a
bunch of binary like binary string based
data it's coming over TCP and look now I
get JSON objects like much more useful
to deal with yes yeah so that that does
happen so if that stream is an object
scream like there's actually a argument
you can pass the week so for the cost of
blood we're dealing with like binary or
text data you can pass like how many
bytes you want to read from it but like
that that's actually does not pull this
object because it won't want to just
give you one object it basically did
text well like when you when you declare
an object moon so now it knows that like
you're like each each push event like
each push on to that internal ray will
always be an object so like it just
makes those decisions it's not trying to
like cost anything for you or set your
video encoding like so it's using a ring
set of a buffer well like actually
that's that's how its I guess it's done
underneath is even with text data like I
mean a right is just ends up being like
a buffer if you're just like appending a
bunch of like offers to it that was like
like these like concatenate buffers and
in the case of object mode now you sound
like an array of objects and that's like
that's that's how it looks entirely ok
so now actually I want to go into all
I'll try to elaborate on this and we're
going to write a little example well it
will read a little HTTP server and doing
some streams all right this data on
mixer I pregnancy oh good ok cool all
right so let's start out over bars HTTP
are like yeah we're going to talk to
file system so we'll do some of that as
well and that's it for now actually or
acquired string just in case and I went
in a moment and I'll allow the port to
be find on the on the CLI just in case I
wanna extend this so I'm just going to
slice the first two arguments off the
array and assume that that first the
next will be the court or I'll default
to 82 so now looks like its creator HTTP
server
hbm conserver given function
Grizz
so we like to deal with some requests
and responses and let's just do slide
basic bike rack checking where so the
recti 0 equals this the rim we're going
to we're going to do like the most basic
thing so we're going to do is that right
head so this side is just establishment
that like okay it's 200 like record and
we're going to just like right hello
sure
and for ended with just to be nice
ok
so
this man is correctly
Oh
we gotta put some new process
everyone
so now I girl this local those a baby
there we go I just wrote some growth
some data to that to that stream or like
if you're if you used to lug using
something like Express or like any of
these frameworks they actually could use
some like some like nicer I guess
methods we're kind of like hide the fact
that this is the stream underneath where
you got the red send or like some have
like a race not JSON so that would just
pass in JavaScript object but in this
case like since I just wrote a string it
like it defaults to me they're taking
like a buffer or a string object and
it'll just like return that down now
let's let's actually do something like
more fun things so little right this
little text Bob and a lot of actually do
the same same to handle oh no Jess you
def and what i see so now this is a file
so now we go back to this
we got you sir
and delete all that and now we're going
to actually really use this like this
Pike method kind of like in that same
example I showed you before we can now
create a restream from this point up txt
file which will every time then request
since that we're drm like it's kind of
like i'll be like oh you gotta grab this
gather a bit by bit and now just
redirected back to that response so now
i'm not doing with any right to the end
it's just going to give me whatever I
whatever I had in that time that txt
file whoop
I actually put that thing that's it too
far in the wrong place then return
Mary
every so now we're just like instead of
just writing that text blatantly 22 batt
response train now we're pulling that
from the file system and then we
recognize response that's just like like
super super basic like stream usage like
using the HP server now do something
like a little bit more interesting so
now let's bring on we're going to make
this new a new grout it's called Brandon
and what this is going to do is it's
going to take a stream of what's dead /
you random from the file system which is
actually just like an unlimited stream
of random information that like your
operating system will give me and I
actually don't I don't want it to be all
binary data because this is going to
actually destroy my terminal because I
turn to like I think macaroons also talk
about this I give you if you type a
bunch of like binary data STD out I get
just the 18 I guess just like completely
like I think it might destroy just my
two months but that's awful so actually
want to actually want to create I don't
want to just do this so I actually want
to create a transform street so we're
going to going to create a little
function here that it's going to return
transform streams so it's random
transform
we're going to do here so transform
equals new stream
so now when it comes to implementing
streams streams to edit these some of
these nice piece where you only like for
a specific transform you only have to
implement one method and that method is
the underscored transformative and that
takes like you get a chunk data and get
whatever the encoding of that data is
and you could call back because these
actually can be sometimes so in this
case okay I don't want to like murder
myself with all this binary data so like
let's just let's turn into something
that is actually like people so I'm just
going to do a to string two hex so now
like it should be like slightly nicer to
me and I'm going to push this to that
internal buffer
what's going on
so now
now that's what that the only function I
even find a now I do is return this
transfunctioner
yeah extreme
I will say we'll see if it blows up on
me oh wow actually totally still
destroyed by terminal
oh yeah thanks there we go see see this
is why exactly why did a lot of pipe
binary data to my seminal now yeah
exactly that was what I didn't want to
do and now we can just pipe to this this
random transform which will return that
function and now piped in response so
now we get like we get some pipe
chaining up
now do the same thing
now we just got like like flowing hex
data it's like okay now that that's
going to let go in for your turn now
soon we want to like we want to do a bit
of like throttling on my data we can
actually change the transform we're like
we can use this little this callback
mechanism that you have so we're going
to put we're going to push the chunk to
the internal buffer but before we're
turning we're going to do a a set time
for let's say how long it's that time
out on this fall back and that will do
like two seconds
now you can see it's like it's getting
it reversed so I every time it like it's
put standing into that into that other
score transform function it's going to
be like okay and write that the hex then
where you two seconds and that would
continue so that's like just an example
like how you can just implement that
like a very simple transform screen like
I mean the usefulness of in this
particular case is questionable but like
it's not just to be guided
well yes so actually what that like what
that set time I would do is it will
prevent like the next chunk from life I
guess coming I guess into that transform
so it's like it's going to wait until I
call that completes before like now that
did it to be crap out of that transform
stream so like the pipe I guess matching
takes that takes care for us but it's
make more clear like that readable event
like wouldn't be called until after that
call back has been executed so by
putting that set timeout it's preventing
you from being told like oh yeah you can
totally read for me was asking is in
your dreams buffer fellow
yes up to like the default buffer limit
i work in floor yep yeah like that's
that's like the beautiful part about
like about pipe is that with now we have
all this interval buffering like it
actually handles that back pressure for
us we're like before and it was actually
I kind of like crazy you had to
implement like you're huggin like your
own back pressure like our like HTTP
proxy module you would like specifically
a make amends like at the correct time
make sure look like the data coming into
the request is then like flushed into
life into that next request like it's
like page painful to try like wrap your
mind around like they're like how is
this all working so now it's like it's
like much easier and Mike simpler okay
so that's like basic fiscal HTTP now
let's get it to you like
well like what does it do so Goodell is
like the module that is the building
block for building like a Marxist and
like this is what we use internally at
which is fun and like actually before I
bargain that the rhesus like I guess
this was britain-based off blog a pop of
the project calling me Mom we're like
green moderate mothers student a fur he
like it's brilliant like event
processing I guess system where you have
all these like all these like stream
like things you basically have this this
particular data format using and Charlie
originally wrote I who wrote can do I
guess took that and like I mean since
all of our honors for structures all
know and it's they just took the
concepts from reabon and just
implemented like no it has the stream
things like the same type of properties
that were being used in remind so it was
like very easy to translate over it made
like the actual maintenance for upkeep
of a piece of software liked by everyone
that our company doing is very like very
fluent JavaScript sound like we're not
not trying to like rock closure and like
dealing with the JVM oh so now we have
to sound like this the same thing
no so like the data format is based on
it's like all right you get it get a
host like you can we do create like a
service and these are just all like
arbitrary keys to define like a message
that would be coming from a network
system so like wanted one of your boxes
it's running a you know we took the web
application it's got what's what's toast
I usually an internal IP address of
sorts like for example we have like some
and draw I've you dressed like the
service the service kind of describes
like what type of message of this it's
useful for like how you do a fill how do
you do filtering on the data so this day
it's like this is just memory state
workers in we're going good use unix
timestamp some kind of some kind of
description you can add arbitrary tags
to your data is going to be useful for
looks like connecting if you're like
sending it off some
and like whatever dimension so this day
is like 1024 so like your applications
using a game of data I'm powerful I
don't know what you're doing but like
that's kind of scary so there are couple
I guess components aagadu where you do
is this event processing thing right we
like to think of them like I guess when
there are two sides of an equation I
guess in like dealing with web stuff
wave like a client sir we're applying in
this case is for like men breton HTTP
application you have like the browser is
a client or like in my examples like
curl was the was a client and the server
was my HTTP server so how how you can
think about Godot is it has the same
client-server relationship except oh
where you put the video client movie on
your actual HTTP server whether it's
like creating logs for you or like
whether you're sending logs in this
specific JSON format or like memory like
memory metrics that that's where it
would good and then you create another
server that they might be chirping like
those know those messages that you're
sending it so like reactors reactors is
like is
component which are actually just
transformed or I kind of but this is
this is the component that lives on the
server and then interprets the type of
data a person so like really it's like a
transform student generator source not
like not the jobs for generators for ya
this factory sounds like terrible
conversations boy oh yeah that's
essentially what it is so in this
example we required to them and then we
create this reactor which is that a
function that the first argument the
first argument of it is always the
source data so this socket is how the
representation of the TCP socket they
are giving except you can now assume
you're dealing with all jobs from
objects so that like that data format i
showed you like up here each if i had
like a non date of event on that socket
each one of those data events would be a
message that looks like that so this in
this particular case I get this socket
and I'm doing I'm doing a particular
filter when like dough has these two the
transform streams like built into it so
this is where is is a filter
where there's a service where it's like
health / heartbeat of any any other
place and then like that stars
interpreters like wiggle expression can
be could be anything so every time those
heartbeat let's send it to this expire
ramp and every time it gets in a bed net
expired after it's going to like reset
the state website okay I read everything
is fine but like it doesn't get a market
message within like 60 seconds then it's
actually going to push a daily event to
that next reactor which is going to
trigger an email out to you like whoever
whoever is your device that's like very
simple like the arbitrary example of
like how you connect up these streets
depression
yeah so the email reactor like how that
works currently is that basically
assumes that you pass it some kind of
off or some kind of like email client
library we kind of default amusing send
grade so you'd actually need some more
properties in there no record to
actually send a message yep yeah so
that's the that's the default pieces
that's like all we needed at identity or
agencies like SendGrid you pass it off
and it like dis triggers the ml and my
default in this has like the JSON blob
is the content and you can set up like
the body of the title like our duties or
the subject so yeah like that's what a
simple service light or you set up this
this pipe chain of just transform sweet
so then assess your data and then you
can send that they're like basically
make assessments on that data and you
could set it off to a gay base you could
trigger email you can do any like
anything pretty much like anything that
can be done that takes like piece of
data assess that data that makes a
decision on it or changes that data in
some way like all that can be done using
this this coral streaming stretch
so the other side of them I can you get
that dear where I told you before we
have this is agent called Forza which is
actually a producer it's a producer it's
written see because most of our users
applications are all written like are
all run on like 256 meg fight like
instances like me to be memory me but
all this is a simple producer that like
creaks JSON of that specific format and
like be able to those go through the day
and like in a sense they are just people
street it's like a readable stream that
just creates data on a particular
interval together that's what the
default Godot got producer will do and
like prefer to just continually produce
data I was like I don't know what you'd
be doing that straining food just
produce some data and then that was it I
guess kind of like it uses priests or
but so you can here's an example where
okay this is what the possibly like
other end of that of that hard you look
like you you have this little window
process running on your server it
connects to the Godot server and every
interval every 15 seconds ago it's just
like fine enough I'm off a message over
TCP and thatthat's just like the very
simple way to like just know that like
your server is always up like that the
whatever data center like your server is
hosted in do just let go down or like
you will you will not know that
definitively so here like an example of
life some producer modules there are too
many company but you do producer and
producer those are just I guess the
abstract forms of like creating your own
specific position where it allows you to
pass left
constructor oh and you just kind of
order do some inheritance and you can
create a specific producer that produces
whatever type of data you want in that
in that format and one thing I wrote
memory producer which the easiest way is
like I just passed some memory producer
into I as a as a good over future and I
get usually get a service so for a lot
of our prep em cam like product services
I just have I just define is like
whatever role that thing is that it's a
proxy I just got that and it will just
continually every every actually every
interval you tell it and he has a
default like 15 seconds for whatever as
a TTL it will just tell you like
whatever whatever the process is using
memory wise it will just like simba
it'll actually it will do a little
calculation in percentage and then there
are these two external producers written
by skin machi where it will monitor your
edits to do some like metrics on like an
external racer and then send those up or
like fur through run like aa proxy in
front of like a bunch of your servers it
you're not a metaphor okay so nothing
like the core concepts I wanna show you
guys a little little demo and we'll see
see if I can actually lock Cougars
yeah wonder how the diapers or that same
i feel you wouldn't count handle the
incoming events possible well then I'll
just drop like that so that's how it
currently works I believe they're gonna
have somebody knickers yes so so I guess
on the on the client if the client can't
send it to the we actually have it like
globe mouth where I like there's any
number of video servers that are I guess
you can think about is low balance with
our proxies except of this TCP process
but then send data to like I guess M
number of other like Windows servers so
it's like load balanced over all of
these so like the probability of that
happening is like is decently low but
currently because I guess the back
pressure would have to be here with my
pcp if anything so if you can't connect
to a server like it will actually just
retry and connect again so DNS will
new like a new a key and oldest stock
settings
yep yeah you can do yeah exactly it all
depends like how much I guess how
valuable the data you're send their time
and like you need easily just want to
like you just fire off like it gets what
it gets and then it's basically an easy
way to rap like send a Mutie PDA or
receiving anything data but then also
being able to use as a stream since we
just parse those messages and then Mike
push it onto like an actual sweet some
gdp unfortunately business group both
all right Matt what am i doing on time
ten minutes okay so because they're like
10 minutes I will actually just show you
like this
that'll be easier so make sure
alright so it's in the idea here XL
shouldn't picture first so this is this
is architecture of like what what I will
wear this like a a simple i can simply
aware all right you have mystery server
say you want you want to scale that or
you will just want you want to set up
proxy in front of it so that when you
deploy like a new one so you want to
update like a brand new server and throw
that into the pool like you don't have
to like there's no pretense of downtime
and because like we live in the world of
virtual machines and they're like we
kind of walked them on I like servers on
on like different virtual machines so
you can just like spin up a new one
tella proxy that yeah because now this
new service even same things too and now
that's the new server group and then you
can like spilling down like do the same
type of uh I guess change for the proxy
to like take that out so what I what I
wrote was a simple a simple proxy that
it's a monitoring on the requests that
were sent to Tunis cease to be serviced
so well take a look at the code okay
so this is this thing the proxy code
this is basically a simple HTTP server
that on each request will like our
betraying the load balance over the to
predefined circus act like they're both
from a local host and what I ought to
reporters and I will also create like
video client so that i can send any of
the data that I'm that I'm producing i
can send that sent along to like to
another nado servers like to process
that I'm just deal with that so that's
just like this is just some overhead of
like setting up the client listen I'm an
Arab egg just so long that it's
something wrong and then if the grocer
wasn't running well tell me when it's
trying like the tempting to reconnect
this video has built in like exponential
bat wealth on its ok so this is just
like the predefined proxy takes a object
that has like a target property which
you can either define as like a host and
important or are you define it as like
just a URL swing and that's that's just
going to send send the data or yeah so
that's just going to be used as an array
where are you just going to I'm going to
like shift and unship for bar shift and
then push to to that array to just like
constantly load balance on the to serve
as I star and then the so where where
I'm actually calculating metrics here is
on on they start and end events
proxy it's going to tell me when the
request begins like so when the proxy
receives the request and then it's about
to like okay now I'm going to like proxy
to this other server it's going to admit
that start a bit then and then whatever
that is completely finished it will it
will tell me when it's done so that'll
give me like a sense of how long that
takes a process that request so you can
think about it like oh like like how
long does it take like I'm gonna take
the route of my HTTP server like how
long does that take to proxy so in this
case I'm just doing like I guess the
arbitrary like whatever whatever route
you're hitting it's just going to like
calculate that and then send send the
send the response I off so it produced
the start of it produces the in event
and then just those little confrontation
like like how long did that take and
then here's the the simple server where
I wish shift target off crossing into
that target and then like push it back
to the array
and then we can look at HTTP server is
pretty much the same thing that we built
on we built on before except I added a
little an automatic ink to this to this
like unending stream usually and but
that's and then I added some like some
logging for when you when you can a
particular round so now I will produce I
will produce a message when we hit the
root beer well and when I hit the random
euro it's just like some some Mexican
like JSON like logging so that's like
that's that's the simple stuff but like
the more more interesting part is like
what is it so what does look at the
server look like what am I my processing
so we have two reactors in this case 1
reactor you're just dealing with a any
arbitrary logs that are coming through
and then just like consoling them you
can think of that kadota console in
reality would be like a long be screen
where you just like send it off of ugly
or you know send that neuritis like
wherever you want a story along with
long stash the reason the reason I I
actually use this term lanham Jitsu is
because a lot of our logging is done on
my comp proxies and like that all the
way you actually like put things into
like into log League or into
one of these other services is like over
HTTP so what I would be doing is like
okay I was proxy which is handling a lot
of requests and then I'd be like wasting
a bunch of sockets just trying to send
send logs over HTTP to like just like
put them somewhere so that's the reason
we're good dough is very useful for our
logs in our case because now I only have
one tcp socket on each these proxies
it's just like pushing data through so
it's not like abusing the sockets that
are actually very valuable for proxima
quest now so all that I like least be be
piped through / 11 single TCP socket and
then same thing with any of the methods
data so this case where we're looking at
like okay where where I get a response
time event we're going to actually use
this then we use the special stream so
we're going to filter by response time
and then relieve the special ice cream
you can think about the you can think of
the x is like a fork so now I'm going to
like I'm gonna slip split this stream
where I'm actually like duplicating data
technically so I'm getting this single
source of data and I'm splitting my host
because I want to do I want to separate
streams on to do like different I guess
different
ehsan so by splitting by host well
actually no it's actually not definite
alignments it's actually just doing a
filter based on each different coasts I
game that's going to go to a different
screen so in the in this case actually
I'll just show you
ok so let's start the video simmer
star is to pee on anyone and then we
will start frosting
so now roxy is running on like 4,000 so
now I send a request ok LexA miss you
perform so that means that when we serve
is the right way
so actually should we should be running
properly but still getting an adventure
to anyway so what's actually happening
here is
it's actually correctly boxing actually
look at the time saying something so on
the on the right side you can now see
that um I'm like I'm logging out the
response time of each request and each
of those is actually calculating a mean
of the response time so for each request
it will it will adjust the mean in each
of those it's actually going to happen
independently of each post so to make
this more clear like okay this took
three milliseconds to to respond on the
glow to say dat and that that change the
average of the response time of the
particular response time average four
lokos 8080 it change that to 2197 now I
do this again now you can see that it's
a completely separate average so what
the what the by screen allows you to do
is like I'm new now I'm doing the same
exact stream logic on two separate
streams like that by strip just allowed
me to like I guess have an easy way to
impose like or to do that same operation
for those two different hosts or which
could be like NM purpose so like this is
actually exactly how I I have a logging
in our pumpkin stretcher is I'm able to
take like okay
I can split by each post for me and then
I can also split by each like user so
like I add that to the service so that
allows me to create me a completely
separate stream that is that's like four
to wear like a nap could have like three
three drums so I split by user and then
I can have just a few a like one single
stream of like all that person's logs
and then send that in to rinse like
click on that on a particular to which
is like they're using a Mac name or like
whatever whatever would be so that's
just like an example showing the powers
powerful like string composition you can
do you would do and just use any
arbitrary stream to like store data and
that's it logout question
so i guess like 0q an axon i guess or
more they're more like powerful keys or
I guess like it doe could be considered
like a very very lightweight Q because
it's just you're sending like data
package over over TCP so I consider
Godot I guess a simpler I guess faster
alternately where the I guess the value
our guests the determinism of your data
because like I have no internal like
covering are queuing built into this
currently so if you do by itself we're
going to try right to a socket and if
that fails to write that like that data
is lost but like there could be a
buffering layer where it's like okay I
can put this into it array and then I
try and raise the socket I failed and i
still have to try again so by building
it away like that then it could be used
as a i guess a cute like thing but the
power i think is just in the be able
able and be able to compose streams in
order to like make decisions and like do
you like calculations it sounds like
zero in view would be possibly on the
train
the power is the same variety you have
more like doing this almost business
logic for life yeah it's like yeah it's
like doing this the separate set of
logging to be like filter out what data
I care about and then maybe like put
that in a cube like put that in a 0 mq I
guess queue system to then be like
process so the extreme position function
they publish and separate modules
well I mean that's actually something I
thought about like they could be like
the body yes between gave our son
function as a 14 or something yes I mean
that's that's something I actually
consider that I do i do like that by
student so I grabbed my web plan is that
these are actually still all screws one
streams technically so when I go and
like refactor that to use like the new
API when like we have streams three and
like there should be no overhead losing
that that like the simpler API that's
actually something I'll probably do
especially to like that one like the
more valuable streams that like you
don't like I guess find anywhere else we
can do that it what else questions
concerns all right well thank you all
for having me yeah yeah I'll actually
all open source the demo now you will be
able to see ya so again my god hamburger
and you can check out my get out twitter
it's all the same but like thank you
very much